Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. To the sound of drums and trumpets, the Spanish flagship unfurled its sails and glided out into Lake Texcoco. From the stern flew a great standard, decorated with a blazing red cross. Behind followed the other 11 ships, the sunlight gleaming on their bronze cannons. And in their wake came hundreds of native canoes, like cygnets trailing a stately swan. At the prow, Hernán Cortés gazed across the lake. There, in the distance, was his goal, the island capital of the Aztecs. For a moment, he seemed to hear his men chanting on the beach before their march to Tenochtitlan,
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。伴随着鼓声和号角声，西班牙旗舰扬起风帆，滑入特斯科科湖。船尾飘扬着一面巨大的旗帜，上面装饰着鲜红的十字架。紧随其后的是另外 11 艘船，阳光照耀在它们青铜色的加农炮上。在它们身后，数百艘土著独木舟紧紧跟随，宛如天鹅幼雏尾随着高贵的天鹅。在船头，埃尔南·科尔特斯凝视着湖面。远处，他的目标就在那里——阿兹特克人的岛屿首都。那一刻，他仿佛听到了部下们在海滩上行军前往特诺奇蒂特兰之前的呐喊声，
what seemed like a lifetime ago. Conquer or die. Conquer or die. Conquer or die, indeed, he thought. The hour of decision was at hand. So that, I mean, it's excellent swan-based metaphors and similes immediately marks it out as Sandbrookian prose. Dominic, we're reaching the climax of this extraordinary story that we originally intended to trace through four episodes, didn't we? And we're now onto our seventh. And I think that that's a reflection not just of the fact that we're naturally prolix, but also that this is just an incredible story. It is an incredible story.
那仿佛是上辈子的事了。征服或死亡。征服或死亡。确实，征服或死亡，他心想。决战时刻已经到来。所以，我的意思是，这些关于天鹅的绝妙隐喻和明喻，立刻就让它带上了桑德布鲁克式的文风。多米尼克，我们正在接近这个非凡故事的高潮，我们最初打算用四集来讲述，不是吗？而现在我们已经讲到第七集了。我认为这不仅反映了我们天生话多，也反映出这是一个令人难以置信的故事。这确实是一个令人难以置信的故事。
When you think where we started, Tom, we started with Hernán Cortés growing up in Medellín, going to Seville, going across to the Caribbean to seek his fortune. I mean, nobody, if they didn't know the story, could possibly have anticipated that we would end with this remarkable scene of them launching this little fleet of 12 ships surrounded by the canoes of their Tlaxcalan and Texcocan allies, Cortes and his men launching these ships into the lake in
汤姆，回想一下我们是从哪里开始的，我们从埃尔南·科尔特斯在麦德林长大，前往塞维利亚，跨海来到加勒比海寻求财富开始。我的意思是，如果人们不知道这个故事，谁能预料到我们最终会以这样一个非凡的场景结束：他们启动了这支由 12 艘小船组成的舰队，周围环绕着特拉斯卡拉和特斯科科盟友的独木舟，科尔特斯和他的部下将这些船只驶入湖中，
the center of Mexico in an attempt to capture the city of this empire that nobody in Europe had previously known existed. It is, as we've said so often, the scene of a fantasy or a science fiction. Yeah. And your children's book, which has inspired us to do these episodes, is called The Fall of the Aztecs. Yes. And we are now approaching that moment, aren't we?
在墨西哥的中心地带，试图夺取这座欧洲人此前闻所未闻的帝国首都。正如我们经常说的那样，这简直是奇幻或科幻小说中的场景。是的。而启发我们制作这些剧集的你的那本童书，书名就叫《阿兹特克的陨落》。是的。我们现在正在接近那个时刻，不是吗？
We are. So just to sort of recap, that scene that you read, so that was the 28th of April, 1521. That was the moment that Cortés launched these brigantines that had been built. We discussed at the end of the last episode, they'd been built far away in Tlaxcala by Martin Lopez, who was the shipwright.
我们确实在接近。所以简单回顾一下，你刚才读到的那个场景，那是 1521 年 4 月 28 日。那是科尔特斯下水这些已建造完成的轻快帆船的时刻。我们在上一集结尾讨论过，它们是由造船匠马丁·洛佩兹在遥远的特拉斯卡拉建造的。
I mean, he wasn't a professional shipwright. I think he was just a carpenter, but Cortes kind of pressed him into service as a shipwright. And they've launched these ships. So Montezuma is dead. His successor, Cuitlahuec, killed by smallpox that has ravaged Mesoamerica. Cortes has teamed up with the Tlaxcalans and other city-states. He has cut off Tenochtitlan from the coast. He has constructed this kind of noose around the Mexica capital.
我的意思是，他并不是专业的造船匠。我想他只是个木匠，但科尔特斯强行让他担任造船匠。他们已经让这些船下水了。蒙特祖马已经死了。他的继任者奎特拉瓦克死于蹂躏了中美洲的天花。科尔特斯与特拉斯卡拉人和其他城邦结成了联盟。他切断了特诺奇蒂特兰与海岸的联系。他在墨西加首都周围筑起了一道绞索。
So they've cut the trade routes. The Mexica are already beginning to run out of food. And now he's really going for the kill. His army, his Spanish army, we've said so many times it's not really an army, but obviously by this point, they are much more of an army. I mean, they're fully militarized. He has 700 infantrymen. He has 100 cavalrymen, hundreds of gunners and crossbowmen. He has installed these guns on the ships. And all the time, as you have been at pains to remind people, more recruits are coming in from the Caribbean and further back from Spain. But the interesting thing, I suppose, Tom, which we've touched on so
所以他们切断了贸易路线。墨西加人已经开始食物短缺。现在他真的要发起致命一击了。他的军队，他的西班牙军队，我们说过很多次，那并不是真正意义上的军队，但显然到了这个阶段，他们更像是一支军队了。我的意思是，他们已经完全军事化了。他有 700 名步兵，100 名骑兵，数百名炮手和弩手。他在船上安装了这些火炮。而且正如你一直不厌其烦地提醒人们的那样，来自加勒比海和更远处的西班牙的增援部队还在不断涌入。但我想，汤姆，有趣的是，我们已经触及了
many times, one of the many issues that lies at the heart of the historiographical debates about the fall of the Aztecs is how much is Cortes calling the shots and how much is this an operation that's really being dominated by the tens of thousands of allies that he has from Tlaxcala and Texcoco and so on? Well, one of the things that has happened since Cortes and his, what was it, a third of his army manages to escape on the Noche Triste. So he's definitely, clearly, the junior partner with the Tlaxcalans at that point. But now more troops have arrived from Europe, and the Tlaxcalans have been devastated by smallpox. So I would imagine that the balance of power must have shifted. Yeah, I think so. Plus, there has been some element of a purge within the Tlaxcalan high
很多次，关于阿兹特克陨落的史学辩论的核心问题之一是：科尔特斯在多大程度上掌握着主导权？而这在多大程度上是一场真正由他从特拉斯卡拉和特斯科科等地招募的数万名盟友所主导的行动？嗯，自从科尔特斯和他的部下——当时大约是他军队的三分之一——在“悲伤之夜”成功逃脱后，发生了一些事情。所以在那时，他绝对显然是特拉斯卡拉人的次要伙伴。但现在更多的军队从欧洲抵达，而特拉斯卡拉人又遭受了天花的重创。所以我认为权力平衡一定已经发生了转移。是的，我想也是。另外，特拉斯卡拉的高层内部也进行了一些清洗。
command. So Cortes has accused some people are plotting against him. Some Cortes skeptics have been eliminated. So there's a guy I mentioned last time, Xico Tincatl the Younger, he is gone, he is dead. And so Cortes within the Tlaxcalan kind of polity, they're now taking a much more Hispanophile line. Right. And the other thing is that the ships are Spanish. Yes. I mean, the other thing is that the ships are Spanish. Yes. I mean, it's the ships that enable the Spanish and the Tlaxcalans to actually get at Tenochtitlan. They do. They do. So the guy who commands the ships is really in pole position, I'd have thought. Yes, he is. So they don't launch the first naval attack until the 1st of June. And there's this extraordinary scene in the Spanish accounts. You know, it really is the stuff of a kind of swords and sandals blockbuster
所以科尔特斯指控有些人密谋反对他。一些怀疑科尔特斯的人被清除了。所以我上次提到的那个人，小希科滕卡特尔，他已经不在了，他死了。因此，在特拉斯卡拉的政体中，他们现在采取了更加亲西班牙的路线。对。还有一件事，这些船是西班牙的。是的。我的意思是，这些船是西班牙的。是的。我的意思是，正是这些船使西班牙人和特拉斯卡拉人能够真正进攻特诺奇蒂特兰。确实如此。所以指挥这些船的人确实处于有利地位，我想。是的，他是。所以他们直到 6 月 1 日才发动第一次海军进攻。在西班牙人的记载中，有一个非凡的场景。你知道，这简直就是那种剑与凉鞋大片的素材，
that Cortes is leading the ships across the lake. They're blasting away with their cannons and their crossbows at the canoes of the Mexica. There's this great fight for a fort, a place called Xoloc, which is halfway across the causeway. With the ships, he's able to win control of the waters, which had previously obviously been dominated
科尔特斯率领船只横渡湖面。他们用加农炮和弩箭猛烈轰击墨西加人的独木舟。为了争夺一座堡垒，一个叫索洛克的地方，也就是堤道中间的一个点，发生了一场大战。有了这些船，他能够夺取对水域的控制权，而这些水域此前显然一直由墨西加人控制。
by the Mexica. And again, it is kind of an amazing scene. And we've used this analogy as well before, those kind of computer games where different civilizations clash with one another so that you can end up having an early modern force attacking a bronze age capital city. That's basically what's happening now. Yes, it is. Although actually, the interesting thing is that the Spaniards do not have it all their own way. So it takes them quite a lot of time from launching the ships at the end of April to making the first really successful naval attack at the beginning of June. And then what happens in the next few days and weeks is we've alluded several times to these causeways. I mean, an extraordinary architectural achievement, by the way, that are linking the city of Tenochtitlan with the lakeside. And for the next few weeks, what Cortés basically does is he divides his forces
这确实是一个令人惊叹的场景。我们之前也用过这个类比，就像那些不同文明相互碰撞的电脑游戏，你可以看到一支近代早期的军队在攻击一座青铜时代的首都城市。这基本上就是现在正在发生的事情。是的，确实如此。尽管有趣的是，西班牙人并没有一切尽在掌握。所以从 4 月底船只下水到 6 月初发动第一次真正成功的海军进攻，他们花了不少时间。接下来的几天和几周里发生的事情，我们已经多次提到这些堤道。顺便说一句，这是一项非凡的建筑成就，连接着特诺奇蒂特兰城和湖岸。在接下来的几周里，科尔特斯基本上把他的部队分成了
into four. So Pedro de Alvarado has a force, a guy called Cristobal de Olid, and Gonzalo de Sandoval. And each of them is given responsibility for taking a different causeway. And what they're doing is they're fighting this really kind of grueling attritional campaign along these causeways along the kind of bridges all the time the aztecs are kind of demolishing the bridges digging big trenches all of this kind of thing sending out sort of sappers to dig pits and stuff and the spaniards meanwhile are trying to inch along the causeway under sort of unceasing barrage of yeah missiles of arrows and trying to fill in the holes getting their engineers to fill in the holes and build bridges across the gap so they can get their troops across and so dominic the person who's in
四部分。所以佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多有一支部队，一个叫克里斯托瓦尔·德·奥利德的人，还有贡萨洛·德·桑多瓦尔。他们每个人都负责攻占一条不同的堤道。他们正在这些堤道上进行一场非常艰苦的消耗战，沿着桥梁不断战斗，阿兹特克人一直在拆毁桥梁，挖掘巨大的战壕，做各种各样的事情，派出工兵去挖坑之类的。与此同时，西班牙人正试图在箭雨的不断轰击下，一点点沿着堤道推进，让他们的工程师去填补坑洞，并在缺口处架设桥梁，以便让他们的部队通过。所以多米尼克，现在在特诺奇蒂特兰的负责人是库奥特莫克，
charge now in tenors titlan is kohotomok yes yeah he's a very impressive figure yeah pretty brutal so it said that he killed one of moctezuma's sons with his own hands. Yes, strangled him, I think. And he's had, what, five others, I think, killed on his orders. And he is the embodiment of no surrender. He is, absolutely. He is. Because I think even at this point, the Spanish are, you know, there are multiple attempts
是的，他是一个非常令人印象深刻的人物，非常残暴。据说他亲手杀死了蒙特祖马的一个儿子。是的，我想是勒死了他。他还下令杀死了另外五个，我想。他是“绝不投降”的化身。他绝对是。因为我认为即使到了这个阶段，西班牙人，你知道，有多次尝试
to negotiate. The Spanish say you must give in. But I suppose at this point, from the point of view of the Mexica, they have everything to lose by surrendering. In desperation, they think, well, maybe if we can hold out, the Spanish will go away. Not least, I think, because they are used psychologically. Well, they have ritualized understanding, don't they? Rhythms of war. They have ritualized warfare of a calendar. So they basically think, well, maybe if we can get to the autumn, the Spanish will all go home and it'll be over and we can rebuild. And they don't envisage that Cortes has a concept of total war, that he is going to cut off all
进行谈判。西班牙人说你们必须投降。但我认为在这一点上，从墨西加人的角度来看，投降意味着失去一切。在绝望中，他们想，也许如果我们能坚持住，西班牙人就会离开。尤其是，我认为，因为他们在心理上已经习惯了。嗯，他们有仪式化的理解，不是吗？战争的节奏。他们有仪式化的战争日历。所以他们基本上认为，也许如果我们能撑到秋天，西班牙人就会全部回家，一切就会结束，我们就可以重建。他们没有预见到科尔特斯有一种全面战争的概念，他要切断他们所有的
their trade, kill all their allies, that he is absolutely going for the jugular. But also, Dominic, in terms of total war, that he is prepared to obliterate their city. I mean, do you think they understand that? No. Doesn't Cortes say, I don't want to destroy your beautiful city? He does. Surrender now.
贸易，杀死他们所有的盟友，他绝对是要直取咽喉。但多米尼克，就全面战争而言，他准备彻底摧毁他们的城市。你认为他们明白这一点吗？不。科尔特斯不是说，我不想摧毁你们美丽的城市吗？他确实说过。现在投降吧。
He does later on. Yes, he does. He says, I don't want to destroy the city, but I will do. So by early June, the Spanish and their allies have basically got control of all the major causeways.
他后来确实说过。是的，他说了。他说，我不想摧毁这座城市，但我会这么做的。所以到了 6 月初，西班牙人和他们的盟友基本上已经控制了所有主要的堤道。
So the city is cut off from supplies. On the 10th of June, Cortes' forces break into the city for the first time. They get as far as the main kind of the big square with all the temples. And then the Aztecs managed to drive them back. But it shows Cortes what can be done. From that point onwards, he thinks, well, if this is going to happen every time, if we're going to penetrate into the city, but then be driven back, the strategy must be to eliminate any possibility of us being ambushed. So flatten the buildings.
所以这座城市被切断了补给。6 月 10 日，科尔特斯率领的部队第一次攻入城内。他们到达了主广场，那里有所有的神庙。然后阿兹特克人设法将他们赶了回去。但这向科尔特斯展示了什么是可以做到的。从那时起，他想，如果每次都这样，如果我们能攻入城内，但又被赶出来，那么策略必须是消除我们被伏击的任何可能性。所以，夷平这些建筑。
Exactly. So let's do a sort of Stalingrad, Berlin, 1945. Yeah, it's a very 20th century approach to total war, isn't it? Absolutely. They are demolishing buildings, burning buildings, basically leaving the defenders nowhere to shelter, nowhere to hide. But I think it would be wrong to suggest there's a total inevitability because by the end of June, for example, the Spanish seem to have all the cards. Almost all the lake towns have either been subdued or joined their alliance. They've got thousands more auxiliaries.
没错。所以让我们来一场斯大林格勒或 1945 年柏林式的战斗。是的，这是一种非常 20 世纪的全面战争方式，不是吗？绝对是。他们正在拆毁建筑，焚烧建筑，基本上让守军无处藏身，无处躲避。但我认为如果说这完全是不可避免的，那就错了，因为到 6 月底，例如，西班牙人似乎掌握了所有主动权。几乎所有的湖畔城镇要么被征服，要么加入了他们的联盟。他们有了数千名更多的辅助部队。
The blockade is very tight. The Aztecs are clearly running out of food. Cuauhtémoc has withdrawn north, to the very north of the city, near the big market at Tlatelolco. But Cortés' own captains are incredibly impatient because they're hungry too, and they're exhausted. And they say to him, come on, hurry up. We must make one last thrust and get this done and dusted. And so, ironically, on the anniversary, Tom, of La Noche Triste, the Night of Tears, the Night of Sorrows. Another one comes up.
封锁非常严密。阿兹特克人显然已经食物短缺。库奥特莫克已经撤退到北方，撤到了城市的最北端，靠近特拉特洛尔科的大市场。但科尔特斯的部下们非常不耐烦，因为他们也饿了，而且精疲力竭。他们对他说，快点，快点。我们必须进行最后一次冲锋，把这件事彻底解决。所以，讽刺的是，汤姆，在“悲伤之夜”的周年纪念日，又一个纪念日到来了。
He decides to go for broke. And he leads all his men in this great charge, hoping they'll break right through into the center of the city and smash the Aztec resistance. And they get quite far, but they walk into, ultimately, yet another Aztec ambush. Is it a bridge too far, Dominic? Very good. A bridge too far. That's the sort of banter you get on the We Have Ways World War II sister podcast. I'm actually recording this in my brother's study. Are you? Surrounded by Second World War memorabilia. So that's perhaps what's influencing it. So you're going to be dropping in random references to Arnhem or to the Battle
他决定孤注一掷。他率领所有部下发动了这次大冲锋，希望他们能直接冲进城市中心，粉碎阿兹特克的抵抗。他们走得很远，但最终还是走进了阿兹特克人的又一次伏击。这是“遥远的桥”吗，多米尼克？说得好。遥远的桥。这就是你在我们的姐妹播客《我们有办法》（We Have Ways）二战节目中会听到的那种调侃。我实际上是在我兄弟的书房里录制这个节目。是吗？周围都是二战的纪念品。所以这可能就是影响它的原因。所以你打算随机插入关于阿纳姆或突出部战役之类的引用吗？嗯，关于被摧毁的城市。我的意思是，在描述这个场景时，很难不想到那些德累斯顿或汉堡在轰炸后的黑白颗粒感照片。嗯，那大概就是当时城市景观的样子。是的。我的意思是，你兄弟的播客没有的一件事是，他们没有来自纳瓦特尔编年史的精彩记载。不，他们没有。他们也没有基于天鹅的散文。他们没有。
of the Bulge or something? Well, to obliterated cities. I mean, it's hard, you know, when describing this, not to think of those grainy black and white photos of Dresden or Hamburg after a bombing campaign. Well, that's presumably, that's what the cityscape is looking like at this point. Yeah. I mean, the one thing your brother's podcast does not have, they don't have lovely accounts from Narwhal chronicles. No, they don't. Nor do they have swan-based prose. They don't.
所以这是一份多年后来自纳瓦特尔人的伏击记录。他说，我们的战士蹲下身子，尽量缩成一团，等待站起来攻击的信号。突然他们听到了。哦，墨西加人，现在是时候了。赫卡辛队长跳起来，冲向西班牙人，大喊：特拉特洛尔科的战士们，现在是时候了。
So this is an account of the ambush from a Narwhal some years later. He says, Our warriors crouched down, making themselves as small as possible, and waited for the call to stand up and attack. Suddenly they heard it. Oh, Mexica, now is the time. Captain Hecatzin leaped up and raced towards the Spaniards, shouting, Warriors of Tlatelolco, now is the time.
然后所有的墨西加人都跳起来冲入战场。西班牙人惊呆了，像喝醉了一样跌跌撞撞，在街上逃窜，我们的战士在后面追赶。我说过这不是不可避免的。在那一刻，科尔特斯很容易就会被杀。因为他被包围了，不是吗？他被包围了。有那么一刻，墨西加战士就在他身边，
Then all the Mexica sprang up and charged into battle. The Spaniards were so astonished that they blundered about as if drunk, fleeing through the streets with our warriors in pursuit. And I said it wasn't inevitable. At this moment, Cortes could easily have been killed. Because he gets surrounded, doesn't he? He is surrounded. And there was a moment when the Mexica warriors are on him
但他们没有杀他。这似乎很合理，因为他们实际上是想俘虏他。然后献祭他。然后献祭他，大概是这样。他们仍然处于那种心态中，习惯于进行那种俘虏敌人的“花之战”。遵守规则。你遵守规则。
and they don't kill him. And it seems plausible that that's because they actually want to capture him. And sacrifice him. And sacrifice him, presumably. They are still in that mindset where they are used to fighting the flower wars where you're captured. Playing by the rules. You obey the rules.
他的保镖设法把他救了出来。我的意思是，他躲过了这么多子弹，不是吗？在这个故事的过程中。他太幸运了。有 21 条命的猫。他太幸运了，但某种程度上，运气是你自己创造的，不是吗，汤姆？我想在殖民这行里是这样。我不知道。
And his bodyguards are able to drag him clear. I mean, he dodges so many bullets, doesn't he? Over the course of this story. He's so lucky. Cat with 21 lives. He's so lucky, but you make your own luck to some extent, don't you, Tom? I guess in this business of colonization. I don't know.
是的，我想是吧。但他的几十名部下被杀，另外 50 人左右被俘。同一位编年史家说，那是一场巨大的俘虏丰收，是献给神庙的巨大祭品。现在，在贝尔纳·迪亚斯的自传中，关于这一切有一个令人惊叹的记载。他说，西班牙人撤退了。他们非常沮丧和狼狈。他们发动了巨大的冲锋，但没有成功。
Yeah, I guess. But a couple of dozen of his men are killed and another 50 or so are captured. And the same chronicler says there was a great harvest of prisoners, a great harvest of victims for the temple. Now, there is an amazing, amazing account in Bernal Diaz's memoir of all this. He says, they withdrew, the Spaniards. They were very downcast and bedraggled. They'd launched their great thrust and it hadn't worked.
他说，随着阳光减弱，我们听到了维齐洛波奇特利的大鼓声从大神庙的顶端回荡，伴随着海螺、号角、喇叭和其他乐器的地狱般的音乐。所以他们听到了所有这些音乐。他们离自己的基地并不远。它就在堤道上。所以他们可以看到神庙非常高，他们可以看到他们被俘的朋友被拖上台阶，走向神庙顶部。
And he says, as the sunlight waned, we heard the great drum of Huitzilopochtli echoing from the summit of the great temple, accompanied by the hellish music of conches, trumpets, horns, and other instruments. And so they hear all this music. They're not that far away in their own base. It's kind of on the causeway. So they can see the temples are so high and they can see their captured friends being dragged up the steps towards the top of the temples.
他们被剥光了衣服，头上装饰着羽毛。我的意思是，显然他们很害怕，他们精疲力竭。迪亚斯写道，祭司们强迫他们在维齐洛波奇特利神面前跳舞。然后他们把他们一个接一个地拉到巨大的祭祀石上。用他们的石刀，他们切开他们的胸膛，掏出他们跳动的心脏，献给神灵。然后他们抓住死者的腿，
And they've been stripped naked and their heads are decorated with feathers. I mean, obviously they're terrified, they're exhausted. And Diaz writes, The priests forced them to dance before the god Huitzilopochtli. Then they stretched them one by one on the great sacrificial stone. With their stone knives, they cut open their chests and tore out their beating hearts and offered them to the gods. Then they took their dead bodies by the legs
把他们从神庙的台阶上扔下去。屠夫们在那里等着切下他们的胳膊和腿，剥下他们脸上的皮，为笼子里的美洲虎、狼、水獭和蛇准备内脏。所以动物园还在正常运转。水獭还在那里。致命的水獭。嗯，水獭还在那里。是的。致命的水獭。嗯，水獭相当致命。
and hurled them headlong down the steps of the temple. There the butchers were waiting to cut off their arms and legs and flay the skin from their faces and prepare their entrails for the jaguars, wolves, otters, and serpents in their cages. So the zoo is still going strong. The otters are still present. The deadly otters. Well, otters are still present. Yeah. The deadly otters. Well, otters are pretty deadly.
水獭会吃掉被剥皮的人吗？小块的。嗯，显然。我的意思是，海獭，它们很凶残，然后它们会和尸体交配。所以这比贝尔纳·迪亚斯想象的还要糟糕。嗯，我不知道这些是不是海獭。这是一个公平的观点。这是一个公平的。
Would an otter eat a flayed man? Little chunks. Well, clearly. I mean, sea otters, they're murderous, and then they have sex with the corpses. So it was even worse than Bernal Diaz imagined. Well, I don't know if these are sea otters or not. That's a fair point. That's a fair.
你知道，总是……有些人会认为那是学究气，汤姆，但我喜欢这种对细节的法医般的关注。嗯，这就是细节，不是吗？细节才是最重要的。我的意思是，这就是这一切的意义所在。你必须筛选每一小块证据。迪亚斯说，我们亲眼目睹了所有这些事情，
You know, always the... Some people would see that as pedantry, Tom, but I like the forensic attention to detail. Well, it's the detail, isn't it? It's the detail that's important. I mean, that's what this is all about. You've got to sift every little fragment of evidence. The LDS says, we saw all these things with our own eyes
从我们的营地里看着，你可以很容易地想象我们的感受。我们离我们不幸的朋友那么近，但我们却什么也做不了。多米尼克，这很有趣，不是吗？我们从营地里看着，亲眼目睹了所有这些事情。我的意思是，这一定相对准确，因为很多人都看到了。是的，我认为这非常可信。所以这是一份关于祭祀的可靠记录。
watching from our camp and you can easily imagine how we felt. We were so close to our unfortunate friends, but we could do nothing at all to help them. Dominic, that's interesting, isn't it? That we saw all these things watching from our camp. I mean, this must be relatively accurate because lots of people saw this. Yeah, I think this is very plausible. So this is a reliable account of sacrifice.
我完全没有理由怀疑这是真的。因为即使你是一个彻底的怀疑论者，你说，啊，西班牙人又在试图抹黑他们了。这些是比喻。是的。你会想，但阿兹特克人很容易就能做到这一点。我的意思是，他们正在进行这场可怕的战争，他们俘虏了一些敌人。他们想恐吓敌人。而且更重要的是，库奥特莫克不知怎么地把信使送了出去，也许是乘独木舟或其他什么东西，我不知道，穿过墨西哥谷，
I see absolutely no reason to doubt that this is true. Because even if you were a total skeptic and you said, ah, once again, the Spaniards are trying to blacken them. They're tropes. Yeah. You would think, but the Aztecs could easily have done this. I mean, they're fighting this horrendous war and they've captured some of the enemy. They want to terrify the enemy. And what's more, Cuauhtémoc somehow smuggles messengers out maybe on canoes or something I don't know across the valley
其中一些人带着西班牙俘虏的手、脚或头颅，向人们展示，
of Mexico and some of them are carrying things like the hands or the feet or the heads of the Spanish captives to show people
在湖畔城镇，告诉人们西班牙人实际上会输掉这场战争，你知道，你应该考虑倒戈。人们会被这个说服吗？
in the lake towns to say the Spanish are actually going to lose this war you know you should think about changing sides are people convinced by this
不，他们实际上并没有，因为人们不是白痴。他们可以看到西班牙人仍然驻扎在堤道上。他们可以看到有成千上万的盟友。而且他们一定也习惯了俘虏会被献祭的事实。所以这看起来可能稍微没那么重要。是的。然后有几周或 10 天左右的相对平静。西班牙人对此感到非常受挫。显然他们中的一些人可能很害怕或受到创伤之类的。但到了 7 月中旬，科尔特斯又开始派遣突袭队
no they're not actually because people are not idiots they can see the Spanish are still there encamped on the causeways they can see there are thousands of allies sides. Are people convinced by this? No, they're not actually, because people are not idiots. They can see the Spanish are still there encamped on the causeways. They can see there are thousands of allies. And they must also be used to the fact that prisoners get sacrificed. And so it must seem slightly less significant. Yes. There's then a couple of weeks or so, or 10 days or something of relative calm. The Spanish are very bruised by this. And obviously some of them are probably terrified or traumatized or whatever. But by mid-July, Cortes is sending raiding parties
去袭击城市。然后关键的是，开始下雨了。你进入了墨西哥的雨季。现在每个人都非常非常疲惫和痛苦。多米尼克，就一个问题。墨西加人对西班牙人穿的金属盔甲、铁头盔等印象非常深刻，不是吗？是的。我们知道他们是否，你知道，这就像《伊利亚特》一样，他们是否在剥下死敌的盔甲并穿在自己身上？还有，我没记错的话，他们拿到了弩，试图研究它们，但无法让它们工作。这绝对正确。是的。他们缴获了枪支，意识到需要火药。
again to hit the city. And then crucially, it starts raining. You're into the rainy season in Mexico. And everybody now is very, very tired and miserable. And Dominic, just one question. The the mashika are terribly impressed aren't they with the metal that the spaniards wear the iron yes the armor the helmets and so on do we know if they you know is it like the iliad are they stripping the corpses of their dead enemies of their armor and putting it on and also aren't i right that they get hold of crossbows and try and work them out but they can't make them work. That's absolutely right. Yeah. And they seize guns and they realize that you need powder.
是的。所以有一种可怕的挫败感，他们得到了这种技术，但无法让它工作。没错。他们无法将西班牙人的技术转而对付他们。顺便说一句，西班牙人正在获得更多的火药。他们发现了一种方法，可以把彼此降到环绕山谷的山脉中的火山火山口里。是的。他们所处的位置非常方便，不是吗？并得到了，我不知道，硫磺或其他什么东西。
Yes. So there's this terrible sense of frustration that they've kind of got this technology, but they can't make it work. Exactly. They can't turn the Spaniards' technology against them. The Spaniards, by the way, are getting more gunpowder. They found out a way of lowering each other into the mouths of the volcanoes in the mountains surrounding the valley. Yeah. They're very conveniently situated, aren't they? And getting kind of, I don't know, sulfur or whatever it is.
硝石。我想是吧。我们从来没有假装是《历史的科学》。《历史的军备》。《历史的弹道学》或军火之类的。但这会有的。肯定的。如果 Gohanger 说了算，那就是《历史的军火》。
Saltpeter. I guess so. We're never pretended to be the rest of science. The rest is armaments. The rest is ballistics or munitions or whatever. But it'll be coming. Definitely. If Gohanger have their way, the rest is munitions.
离那一天只有几周了。他们会找谁来主持？我不知道。某个前准将和你兄弟，汤姆。我兄弟是军事历史学家，所以他会知道军队行军靠胃是多么重要，我不知道被围困的人民做什么，但他们也对他们的食物非常感兴趣，而墨西加人基本上已经没有食物了，所以他们饱受疾病蹂躏，现在完全没有食物了，所以我们再次有了一个关于此的很好的编年史。唯一的食物是蜥蜴、燕子、硬玉米棒和湖里的盐草。人们吃睡莲、花和种子，
It's only weeks away. Who would they get to present it? I don't know. Some former brigadier and your brother probably tom my brother's got other things other fish to fry well your brother is a military historian so he will know how important that an army marches on its stomach and i don't know what a besieged people do but they are also interested in their very much and the mashika have basically run out of food so they are ravaged by disease they've now totally run out of food so again we have a good chronicle about this the only food was lizards swallows hard corn cobs and the salt grasses of the lake people ate water lilies flowers and seeds
咀嚼鹿皮和皮革碎片。他们吃最苦的杂草，甚至吃土。没有什么能比得上围城的恐怖。没有什么能比得上饥饿的痛苦。从如此富足到如此饥饿。嗯，这是经典的围城故事，不是吗？一旦守军开始挨饿，他们就真的陷入困境了。此外，命运以一种非常奇怪的方式落入了科尔特斯的手中，因为我们已经提到过几次北方那个巨大的岛屿，人们相信它是，他们称之为“拉佛罗里达”，是的，花开之地，他们确信青春之泉就在那里，这太
and chewed on deer hides and pieces of leather they ate the bitterest weeds they even ate dirt nothing compares with the horror of the siege. Nothing could equal the agonies of the starving. To go from such plenty to such starvation. Well, it's the classic siege story, isn't it? Once the defenders start to starve, they're really up against it. Also, fate in a really weird way plays into Cortes' hands because we've mentioned a few times this giant island to the north that people believe is, they call la florida yeah the flowering place and they are convinced that the fountain of youth is there it's so
有趣了，西班牙人一方面生活在一个最坚韧、最冷酷的地缘政治现实世界中，但另一方面他们仍然有这些奇怪的浪漫观念，是的，来自骑士故事，他们由这个家伙领导，当我第一次读到时，我一直以为他叫胡安·庞塞，你呢？德莱昂，
interesting how the spanish are living in a world of the most gritty grim geopolitical realism on the one hand and yet they still have these weird romantic notions yes from the chivalric stories and they're led by this guy who when I first read I always thought he was called Juan Ponce did you? De Leon
是的，觉得那很有趣，舌头的主人，是的，所以胡安·庞塞·德莱昂，是的，他领导了
yeah find that very funny the master of tongues yeah so Juan Ponce De Leon yeah he has led
一次寻找青春之泉的探险，结果却出了大问题，他死了。幸存者回来了，他们正在回加勒比海的路上，但他们在维拉克鲁斯停了下来。他们基本上被拦截了。
an expedition to find the fountain of youth and foreigner it's gone horribly wrong he's dead the survivors come back and they're on their way back to the Caribbean but they stop in Vera prison. They get basically waylaid.
所以现在又有数百人带着更多的火药、更多的补给来到了湖边，这些补给来自这次失败的佛罗里达探险。所以科尔特斯绝对占据了上风。在这一点上，他向库奥特莫克提出了条件。我猜他再次通过梅林切这样做。他说，接着你刚才说的话，汤姆，特诺奇蒂特兰是世界上最美丽的东西。他讨厌摧毁它的想法。这一定是真的，不是吗？所有来自西班牙人的记录，他们都被这座城市的美丽所震撼，然而他们却是最终摧毁它的人。对此一定会有某种程度的遗憾。是的，我想是这样。我想尤其是因为你摧毁得越多，
So hundreds more men pitch up now at the lake with more gunpowder, more supplies from this failed expedition to Florida. And so Cortes definitely has the upper hand. At this point, he offers Cuauhtémoc terms. Again, I'm guessing he does this through Melinche. He says, picking up what you said, Tom, Tenochtitlan is the most beautiful thing in the world. He hates the thought of destroying it. And that must be true, mustn't it? All the records from the Spaniards, they are so stunned by the beauty of the city, and yet they are the people who end up destroying it. And there must be a measure of regret at that. Yes, I think so. I think not least because the more you destroy,
你最终得到的财富就越少。是的，当然。我对他们动机的理解过于诗意了。但汤姆，你知道吗？我们读到的那段，似乎是 23 集前来自贝尔纳·迪亚斯的关于伊斯塔帕拉潘的描述，关于它有多美以及那种遗憾。没有理由怀疑它的真实性。不，我不认为，是的。我认为西班牙人不是，你知道，他们可能非常残暴，
the less wealthy you'll be at the end of it. Yeah, of course. I'm being unduly poetic in that understanding of their motives. But Tom, do you know what? That thing that we read out, what seems like 23 episodes ago from Bernal Diaz's, about Iztapalapan, how beautiful it was and the regret. There's no reason to doubt the veracity of that. No, I don't think, yeah. I think the Spaniards are not, you know, they may be being very brutal,
但这并不是他们性格的唯一要素。我认为，对于我们来说，这个故事的恐怖之处在于一种奇怪的方面，那就是对可能幸存下来的东西的感受。是的，因为幸存下来的东西太少了。
but that is not the only element of their characters. And I think that that is a kind of peculiar aspect of the horror of this story for us, is the sense of what might have survived. Yes, because so little of it does survive.
那种令人惊叹的城市的感觉，描述是如此令人难忘和诗意，以至于这一切都消失了的遗憾是可怕的。是的，因为库奥特莫克没有接受这笔交易。他没有接受，实际上是因为一个很好的理由，他和他的顾问们说，听着，科尔特斯一次又一次地证明了他不可信。
The sense of this stunning city, the descriptions are so haunting and poetic that the regret that it's all gone is terrible. Yeah, because Cuauhtémoc doesn't take the deal. He doesn't take it actually for the very good reason that he and his advisors say, listen, Cortes has proved again and again that he cannot be trusted.
所以他们拒绝了这笔交易，围城战加倍了。显然终局即将到来，我们将在下半场进入终局，但我们也会进入一个我知道你非常兴奋的元素，我们将进入人们打扮成猫头鹰的元素，哦是的，格查尔猫头鹰，是的，所以不要走开，因为休息后人们会打扮成猫头鹰，我的意思是，没有人们打扮成猫头鹰，那算什么戏剧性的故事。巨大的兴奋即将到来。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《历史的娱乐》。这是你每周的
So they turn down the deal and the seedery doubles. Clearly the end game is approaching and we will get to the end game in the second half time but we'll also get to something that i know you're very excited about we will get to the element of people dressing up as owls oh yes the quetzal owl yes so don't go away because people will be dressing up as owls after the break i mean what is a dramatic story without people dressing up in owls. Huge excitement to come. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman, and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of
娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先观看现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》，我们已经真正进入了阿兹特克的陨落。
entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History, and we are well and truly into the fall of the Aztecs.
多米尼克，在上一部分的结尾，你向大家承诺了猫头鹰。所以，当我还是个孩子的时候，我读过休·托马斯那本关于西班牙征服的巨大砖头般的记录。我真正记得的一件事就是这个打扮成猫头鹰的家伙。据我记忆，这就像发动核攻击一样。是的。这是终极武器。这是他们一直保留的终极武器。他们不想使用它，因为他们知道这基本上会毁灭世界。这个家伙打扮成猫头鹰，他们认为这不管是什么，我们都要一起完蛋了。他走出去，
And Dominic, at the end of the previous section, you promised people owls. So I read, when I was a child, I read Hugh Thomas's enormous, great brick of an account of the Spanish conquest. And really the one thing I remember is this guy who gets dressed up as an owl. And as I remember it, it's kind of the equivalent of launching a nuclear attack. Yeah. It's the ultimate weapon. It's the ultimate weapon that they've been keeping it in reserve. They don't want to use it because they know that it basically will end the world. This bloke dresses up as an owl and they think this is whatever, we're all going to go down together. And he goes out
然后就像印第安纳·琼斯一样，西班牙人射杀了他。是这样吗？我的记忆混乱了吗？你没说错。事情基本上就是这样发生的。顺便说一句，休·托马斯的书，对于不知道的人来说，大约有 7000 页长。是的，它非常长。它奇怪地既非常非常详细，又奇怪地有点无聊，我想。是的，它很无聊，但这部分是我记得的，唯一的部分。所以我们在上半场结束时谈到了拒绝科尔特斯的条件。佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多，顺便说一句，他一直从西面进攻，佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多，你模仿汤姆模仿得很好。他的部下后来曾说，他一直很慢
and then it's like Indiana Jones, Spanish to shoot him. Is that right? Is my memory garbled? You're not far wrong. That's pretty much what happens. So the Hugh Thomas book, by the way, for people who don't know, it's about 7,000 pages long. Yeah, it's very long. It's weirdly both very, very detailed and oddly a bit boring, I think. Yeah, it is boring, but this is the bit I remember, the one bit. So we ended the first half quite saying about turning down Cortez's offer of terms. Pedro de Alvarado, who's been attacking from the West, by the way, Pedro de Alvarado, you do an excellent impersonation of Tom. His men said afterwards, he had been very slow
在切断西部堤道和进入城市方面，因为他的情妇兼妻子唐娜·路易莎住在西岸。所以基本上每天五点，无论他们在哪里，他说，好吧，我得回去了。我回去了，这样他就能和她共度夜晚。他的部下对此非常不满，有很多抱怨。嗯，他必须巩固特拉斯卡拉与西班牙的联盟。显然他必须这样做。他对多元化和包容性很感兴趣。他正在润滑外交的轮子。他是。这是一个很好的说法。所以他终于突破了，包容性，他正在润滑外交的轮子，他是，这是一个
at cutting the Western causeway and getting into the city because his mistress stroke wife, Donna Louisa was based on the Western Bank. And so basically at five o'clock every day, wherever they were, he said, right, I've got to go back. I went back so he could spend the night with her. And his men were very displeased about this, a lot of grumbling. Well, he had to cement the Tlaxcalan Spanish alliance. Clearly he did. He's interested in diversity and inclusion. He's oiling the wheels of diplomacy. He is. That's a nice way of putting it. So he's finally broken through and inclusion he's oiling the wheels of diplomacy he is that's
很好的说法，所以他终于突破到了大市场的边缘，特拉特洛尔科的市场，科尔特斯把他的总部搬到了城内，幸存的墨西加人现在真的被困在城市的北部，阿尔瓦拉多正在领导最新的进攻，这时这个非凡的幻影出现了。他和他的部下惊呆了。所以实际上，他们并没有立刻射杀他，汤姆。他们惊呆了。他们中的一些人被恐惧所笼罩，因为那是一个人，或者更确切地说是一只鸟，装备着箭，从头到脚穿着那种闪闪发光的绿色和金色羽毛。是的。这就是
a nice way of putting it so he's finally broken through to the edge of the great market the marketplace at slatololco cortez moves his headquarters inside the city the surviving mexica are really penned in now in the north of the city and alvarado is leading the latest attack when this extraordinary apparition appears. And he and his men are stunned. So actually, they don't shoot him straight away, Tom. They are stunned. And they are struck, some of them, with terror because it is a man, or rather a bird, armed with arrows and clad from head to toe in sort of gleaming green and gold feathers. Yeah. And this is the Quaming green and gold feathers. Yeah.
格查尔猫头鹰战士。是的。正如你所说。是的。一个辉煌、辉煌的场景，也是一个悲剧的场景。格查尔猫头鹰战士。所以阿兹特克人在战斗时，通常会在最后把他带出来。
And this is the Quetzal Owl Warrior. Yeah. As you say. Yeah. A brilliant, brilliant scene and a tragic scene. The Quetzal Owl Warrior. So what the Aztecs would do is when they were fighting their battles, normally they would bring him out at the end.
这是一个仪式性的元素，一个人突然出现，打扮成猫头鹰，是的，这是一种当你快赢的时候会做的事情，你的敌人会惊恐地扔下武器，欢呼我们赢了，实际上这个看起来像传说中超级英雄的人物，实际上是一个叫波奇辛的人，因为他的力量和勇气而被选中，所以他被塞进这套猫头鹰服里，你喜欢这个，我喜欢它，我的意思是，认真地说，这对我来说体现了阿兹特克帝国崩溃的悲剧感，因为当然，它有各种各样的黑暗面，是的，但它也有，我的意思是，一种文化上的美和诗意，以及它的习俗在面对这种可怕的入侵力量时的不足，我认为是非常非常痛苦地
And this is a ritualistic element that a man suddenly appears dressed as an owl yeah and this is sort of you do this when you're winning your enemies throw down their weapons and terror hurrah we've won and actually this figure that appears to be like a superhero from the annals of legend is actually a man in a suit called a poch sin who's been chosen for his strength and courage so he's crammed into this owl suit you like this i love it and i mean seriously this embodies for me a sense of the tragedy of the collapse of the aztec empire because of course there's all kinds of darkness to it yeah but there is also i mean a kind of beauty and poetry to its culture and the inadequacy of its customs to deal with this terrifying invasion force is i think very very painfully
体现了这一集，我认为这很公平，汤姆，我的意思是，这很有趣，这是一种黑暗的喜剧，但我认为它也有一层深刻的悲剧色彩。哦，绝对有。所以关于墨西加帝国的事情是，它有黑暗面。当然，我们现在觉得人祭令人反感，剥皮和不给糖就捣蛋让我们觉得至少在政治上是有问题的，我想。有力。是的，有力。但这是一个美丽的文明。伟大的诗歌、民谣、哲学、艺术，所有这些东西。以及一种超越我们理解的神话感。是的。偶尔当你听到这样的故事时，
embodied by this episode i think that's fair tom i mean it is funny it is kind of darkly comic but it is also i think deeply you, there's a deep vein of tragedy to it as well. Oh, there definitely is. So the thing about the empire of the Mexica is there is darkness to it. Of course, the human sacrifice we find revolting now, the flaying of men and trick-or-treating strikes us as at the very least politically questionable, I think. Punchy. Yeah, punchy. But it's a beautiful civilization. Great poetry, ballads, philosophy, arts, all of this stuff. And a kind of a sense of a mythology that is just beyond our grasp. Yeah. That occasionally when you hear stories like this
关于猫头鹰，你会感觉到，嗯，对宇宙的理解，以及人类与神性关系的本质，以及一切，什么体现在其中？当然，你可以阅读关于它的研究和历史，但它已经消失了。是的，我们永远不会知道。我们永远不会知道。因为实际上，正如你所说，这是一个，对我们和听这个播客的人来说听起来很荒谬，一个打扮成猫头鹰的人。但在当时，他身后有祭司在吟诵这些祈祷文。向我们的敌人射出神圣的箭，那是火之蛇，穿透火的箭。向入侵者射出它。用维齐洛波奇特利的力量把他们赶走。我的意思是，他们并不是讽刺地做这件事。
about the owl, you sense, well, what understandings of the cosmos and the nature of the relationship of humanity to the divine and everything, what is embodied in that? And of course, you can read studies and histories of it, but it's gone. Yeah, we'll never know. We'll never know. Because actually, as you say, this is a, it sounds ludicrous to us and to the people listening to this podcast, a bloke dressed in an owl suit. But at the time, there are priests behind him who are chanting these kinds of prayers. Loose the sacred arrow at our enemies, which is the serpent of fire, the arrow that pierces the fire. Loose it at the invaders. Drive them away with the power of Huitzilopochtli. I mean, they're not doing that ironically.
不，当然不是。他们完全投入其中。我的意思是，这就是为什么我发现卡米拉·坦赞的书，我们之前提到过，《第五个太阳》。我的意思是，我读过的最令人难忘和感人的历史书之一，因为它确实感觉像是一种复活主义的壮举，以至于我觉得我现在可以理解阿兹特克人了。多亏了那本书。嗯，因为她所做的是，她得到了很多纳瓦特尔语的资料，以前相对
No, of course not. They are totally invested in this. I mean, that's why I found Camilla Tanzan's book, which we've mentioned before, The Fifth Sun. I mean, one of the most haunting and moving history books I've ever read, because it did feel like a feat of resurrectionism to the degree that I feel I can now understand the Aztecs. It's thanks to that book. Well, because what she's done is she's got lots of Nahuatl sources, previously relatively
不，当然不是。他们完全投入其中。我的意思是，这就是我找到卡米拉·坦赞（Camilla Tanzan）那本书的原因，我们之前提到过，书名叫《第五个太阳》（The Fifth Sun）。我的意思是，这是我读过的最令人难忘、最感人的历史书之一，因为它确实感觉像是一种复活主义的壮举，以至于我觉得我现在可以理解阿兹特克人了。这要归功于那本书。嗯，因为她所做的是她收集了许多纳瓦特尔语（Nahuatl）的资料，这些资料以前相对
untouched, and has really dug into them and extracted every last drop of meaning and significance. But I think she writes as someone in love with the culture that she's writing about. And that sense of love is, I mean, she's not soft-soaping the brutality and the horror that underpins every great civilization, but there is love there. Yeah, I think that's fair. So anyway, the Quetzal Owl, he doesn't last very long. He sort of dances on the roofs, and the Spaniards are stunned at first.
未曾触及，并深入挖掘了它们，提取出了每一滴意义和重要性。但我认为她写作时，就像一个爱上了她所描写文化的人。那种爱意，我的意思是，她并没有粉饰支撑每一个伟大文明的残酷和恐怖，但其中确实存在爱。是的，我认为这很公允。总之，那个魁札尔猫头鹰，他没能坚持太久。他在屋顶上跳舞，西班牙人起初惊呆了。
But in the account that we have, they close in around him eventually. And then he's sort of seen to fall or drop or something. And then he's never seen again. And you can well imagine that basically the Spanish have just butchered him. So that's the end of him. I think with that, in a weird way, that really is the sort of emotional climax for the Aztecs, for the defenders of the siege. So they fight on for only a few more days. Cortes sends another message. Have you no pity for your old men, your women and children? Still, they turn
但在我们现有的记载中，他们最终包围了他。然后他似乎被看到跌倒或坠落之类的。之后就再也没人见过他。你可以想象，基本上西班牙人已经把他屠杀了。所以这就是他的结局。我认为，以一种奇怪的方式，这确实是阿兹特克人，也就是围城守军的情感高潮。所以他们又坚持战斗了几天。科尔特斯又派人传话：你们对老人、妇女和儿童没有怜悯之心吗？他们依然拒绝了。
it down. More and more Spanish assaults. There are bodies of now civilians piling up in the streets. And on the night of the 12th of Augustust we are told the aztecs see a comet blazing like a bonfire in the sky that sort of fizzes in the air and then plunges into the water we're told the people knew what it meant and they watched in silence i mean that's again that that is cinematic of course it is of course it is again one of those details that you think is that too good to be true but in a way i mean at this point you're just going to invest in the melodrama the story aren't you doesn't pay to be too skeptical i would say poetry rather than melodrama yeah i think that's fair tom melodramatic poetry maybe no just poetry i don't think it's melodramatic so the following day the 13th of um aug August, the Spanish launched their final attack.
更多的西班牙人发动了进攻。现在街道上堆满了平民的尸体。在8月12日的夜晚，据记载，阿兹特克人看到一颗彗星在天空中像篝火一样燃烧，在空气中发出嘶嘶声，然后坠入水中。我们被告知人们知道这意味着什么，他们沉默地注视着。我的意思是，这再次显得非常有电影感，当然是这样，当然是这样。这又是那种让你觉得“这是否好得令人难以置信”的细节之一，但在某种程度上，我的意思是，到了这一步，你只会沉浸在情节剧的故事中，不是吗？没必要太怀疑。我会说是诗意而非情节剧。是的，我认为这很公允，汤姆。也许是情节剧式的诗歌？不，只是诗歌，我不认为这是情节剧。所以第二天，8月13日，西班牙人发动了最后的进攻。
It's a scene from a sort of apocalyptic war film. The remaining civilians, hundreds of them, are sort of stampeding down to the lake, desperate to get across in canoes. In the stampede, many of them are probably crushed. Some of them fall into the water and drown because, of course, a lot of them can't swim. Those canoes that are trying to get across are being attacked by the Spanish ships. At one point, one of Cortes' ship's captains, a guy called García Holguín, who comes from the same region of Spain as Cortes, Extremadura, he notices that one canoe, the people seem to be better dressed than the others. He
这就像是一部末日战争电影中的场景。剩下的数百名平民正蜂拥冲向湖边，拼命想乘独木舟渡湖。在踩踏中，他们中的许多人可能被压死了。有些人掉进水里淹死了，因为当然，他们中很多人不会游泳。那些试图渡湖的独木舟正受到西班牙船只的攻击。有一次，科尔特斯的一位船长，一个叫加西亚·奥尔金的人，他来自科尔特斯的家乡西班牙埃斯特雷马杜拉，他注意到有一艘独木舟上的人似乎比其他人穿得更好。他
kind of zeroes in on that canoe. They chase it down. It turns out that this canoe is carrying Cuauhtémoc, last emperor of the Mexica. And he is dragged out of the canoe, taken out. And he is taken to the rooftop headquarters near the great marketplace where Cortés and Alvarado and Malinche are waiting. And the story is that Cuauhtémoc is shown in and Cortés stares at him and then pats him on the head and then tells him to sit and they sit down. Cuauhtémoc, who is a
盯上了那艘独木舟。他们追了上去。结果发现这艘独木舟上载着墨西加人的最后一位皇帝夸特莫克。他被从独木舟里拖了出来，带走了。他被带到了大市场附近的屋顶总部，科尔特斯、阿尔瓦拉多和马林切正在那里等待。故事是这样的：夸特莫克被带进来，科尔特斯盯着他看，然后拍了拍他的头，让他坐下，于是他们坐了下来。夸特莫克，一个
broken man, says, I did everything to save my kingdom from you. But now that you've won, fate has turned against me. You've destroyed my city. You've killed my people. I urge you to take my life. And Cortez says, no, I'm sorry that you foolishly turned down my offers. But when this is all over, of course you'll rule your city just as you did before. Cortez is still the sort of, things like this made me see him as a smooth, plausible, utterly untrustworthy man. Yeah. But why is he saying that? I don't know. I genuinely don saying that? I don't know. I genuinely don't know.
破碎的人，说：“我竭尽全力从你们手中拯救我的王国。但既然你们赢了，命运已经背离了我。你们摧毁了我的城市，杀害了我的子民。我恳求你取走我的性命。”科尔特斯说：“不，我很遗憾你愚蠢地拒绝了我的提议。但当这一切结束后，你当然会像以前一样统治你的城市。”科尔特斯依然是那种……这类事情让我觉得他是一个圆滑、貌似有理、完全不可信的人。是的。但他为什么要这么说？我不知道。我真的不知道。
I don't know whether he's saying it because he thinks he can use Cuauhtemoc as he once hoped perhaps to use Montezuma. Is he saying it because it's expected of him to be gallant in victory? Is the source even correct? You know, it's only one source. Is there some classical cosplay?
我不知道他这么说是因为他认为可以利用夸特莫克，就像他曾经希望利用蒙特祖马那样。他是因为在胜利时被期望表现得风度翩翩才这么说的吗？来源甚至准确吗？你知道，这只有一个来源。这是否是一种古典式的角色扮演？
Exactly. There's so much of that with Cortez, isn't there? Yeah, I think there is. Yeah. You get a sense of him now. He's still only 35. I think you get a sense of him from some of these stories. You can imagine him as a young man in Salamanca reading the stories of Julius Caesar or of Alexander, and now he's acting them out. Well, he's like an Alexander who's captured Darius. Exactly that, Tom. Exactly that. But this is an empty promise. So that night, the 13th, it just rains for hours and hours. And the next morning, it's one of those sort of scenes like from the very, very last episode of Game of Thrones.
正是如此。关于科尔特斯，有很多这样的情况，不是吗？是的，我想是这样。是的。你现在对他有了一种感觉。他当时才35岁。我想你从这些故事中对他有了一种了解。你可以想象他作为一个在萨拉曼卡读书的年轻人，读着尤利乌斯·凯撒或亚历山大的故事，而现在他正在演绎这些故事。嗯，他就像一个俘虏了大流士的亚历山大。正是那样，汤姆。正是那样。但这只是一个空头支票。所以那天晚上，13号，雨下个不停。第二天早上，那场景就像《权力的游戏》最后一集一样。
The city is all destroyed and in ruins. There's a real sense of the kind of morning after the night before. Steam rising from the rubble. The bedraggled feathers of the owl warrior. Exactly. Exactly. Exactly, Tom. So Cuauhtémoc is brought into the ruins of the palace, and he is wearing his imperial
城市被彻底摧毁，沦为废墟。有一种真正意义上的“事后清晨”的感觉。蒸汽从瓦砾中升起。猫头鹰战士那凌乱的羽毛。正是如此。正是如此。正是如此，汤姆。所以夸特莫克被带进了宫殿的废墟中，他穿着他的帝国
finery, but it is all kind of muddy and tattered, and he looks a very downcast figure. And Cortes, his tone has changed now. The sort of smiling smoothness of the day before is gone. Cortes, as you can imagine him, him sitting on a big chair or throne or something and saying, where is the gold? You know, let's cut to the chase. Where's the gold? And Cuauhtémoc says nothing, but some of his men go out under guard
盛装，但一切都沾满了泥土，破烂不堪，他看起来是一个非常沮丧的人物。而科尔特斯，他的语气现在变了。前一天那种微笑的圆滑感消失了。你可以想象科尔特斯坐在大椅子或宝座上说：“黄金在哪里？”你知道，开门见山吧。黄金在哪里？夸特莫克什么也没说，但他的一些手下在守卫的监视下走了出去，
and they faff around a bit with their canoes. And then they come back and they basically bring out the gold that they'd hidden in the canoes to take across the lake when they were trying to escape. It's golden masks, it's the usual trinkets and stuff. And Cortes says, I'm not asking about these pathetic little trinkets. I want the good stuff. Where's all the gold was in the palaces. It was in Montezuma's palace. You took it and you lost it in the night of tears. And Cortes says, in that case, it must be in the lake. And if it's there, you will find it. I will force you to find it. And Malinche, we're told, says, I mean, she's all in with the Spaniards by now.
他们用独木舟折腾了一会儿。然后他们回来，基本上拿出了他们藏在独木舟里试图逃离湖泊时带走的黄金。那是金面具，通常的小饰品之类的。科尔特斯说：“我不是在问这些可怜的小饰品。我要的是好东西。所有的黄金都在宫殿里。它在蒙特祖马的宫殿里。你们拿走了它，并在悲伤之夜丢失了它。”科尔特斯说：“如果是这样，它一定在湖里。如果它在那里，你会找到它。我会强迫你找到它。”我们被告知马林切说——我的意思是，她现在完全站在西班牙人这一边了。
Because triumph for her. Triumph for her, exactly. She says, you must bring us 200 bars of gold and she gestures with her hands to show how much she wants and the advisor says rather weakly well perhaps the common people took it perhaps they took it from the lake so that evening cortez organizes a victory feast for his men and he organizes it not in the city but in the lake town of coahuacan, which is on the south side of the lake and is today a suburb of Mexico City. It's where you can see the Frida
因为这对她来说是胜利。对她来说是胜利，没错。她说：“你必须给我们带来200块金条。”她用手势比划着她想要多少。顾问相当虚弱地说：“也许是普通百姓拿走了，也许他们从湖里拿走了。”所以那天晚上，科尔特斯为他的手下组织了一场胜利宴会，他不是在城里，而是在湖边的科约阿坎镇组织的，它位于湖的南侧，今天已是墨西哥城的一个郊区。在那里你可以看到弗里达·卡罗博物馆等景点。那里还有科尔特斯后来建造的总部，他的宫殿，至今仍在那里。那是一个非常值得一游的地方。科尔特斯有从西班牙带来的葡萄酒。有大量的食物和饮料。故事是说他大部分手下都喝得烂醉如泥，在桌子上跳舞。他们离开时醉得厉害，在街上摔倒之类的。与此同时，当然，在城里，是一片绝望的景象。第二天早上，他们基本上清空了这座城市。所以难民们开始沿着堤道走出来，成千上万的人。他们已经几周没吃过像样的饭了。
Kahlo Museum, among other things. It's where you see Cortes' headquarters that he then built, his palace, is still there. It's an amazing place to walk around. Cortes, he has wine that's been brought from Spain. There's lots of food and drink. The story is that most of his men get absolutely wasted and they're dancing on the tables. They're so drunk when they leave, they're falling over in the streets and stuff. Meanwhile, of course, in the city, a scene of total despair. And the next morning, they basically empty the city. So the refugees start coming along the causeway, hundreds and thousands of people. They haven't eaten properly for weeks.
他们完全心烦意乱。他们正在遭受可能想象到的最可怕的心理创伤。这就像第二次世界大战结束时的场景之类的。他们穿过堤道，走到一半时，西班牙士兵在等着。他们把他们分开。同样，必须说，这是一个非常二战的场景。他们带走了年轻女性，她们将成为他们的奴隶。显然，通常她们是性奴隶。然后是年轻男性，他们在他们的脸上烙印，通常是“G”，即“Guerra”，战争。他们被宣布为西班牙国王的叛军。
They are utterly distraught. They're suffering the most appalling psychological trauma that can possibly be imagined. It's like a scene from the end of the Second World War or something. And they go across the causeway, and halfway across, the Spanish soldiers are waiting. They separate them out. Again, a very Second World War scene, it has to be said. They take away the young women who will become their slaves. Obviously, often they're sexual slaves. And then the young men, they brand them on their faces, often with the G, guerra, war. They're declared rebels against the King of Spain.
因为，当然，这是整个事情所基于的虚构。这是一场叛乱。这是一场叛乱。而不是一场征服战争。是的。基于这是一场叛乱。这是一场叛乱。而不是一场征服战争。是的。我们被告知他们搜查了每个人的黄金，他们搜查了你身体的每一个部位。所以这些是非常侵入性的搜身。是的，非常激进、侵入性的搜查。他们在人们的嘴里、耳朵里到处寻找黄金。然后难民们穿过了堤道，那些没有被带走做奴隶的人，当然，当他们到达另一边时——
Because, of course, this is the fiction that the whole thing is based on. That it's a rebellion. It's a rebellion. Not a war of conquest. Yeah. based on that it's a rebellion it's a rebellion not a war of conquest yeah and we are told they searched everybody for gold and they searched in every part of your body so these are very intrusive body searches yeah very aggressive intrusive searches they are looking in people's mouths and their ears everywhere for gold and then the refugees get across those that haven't been taken away as slaves and of course when they get to the other side-
什么都没有。是的，什么都没有。他们失去了——是的，这是一个地狱般的景象。绝对的一切。我们将再做一期节目来谈谈这对科尔特斯、墨西哥、阿兹特克人的后果，并反思这作为旧世界和新世界相遇历史中的一个片段，以及欧洲殖民化的故事。
There's nothing. Yeah, there's nothing. They have lost- Yeah, it's a hellscape. Absolutely everything. And we'll do one more episode to talk about the consequences for Cortez, for Mexico, for the Aztecs, and to reflect on this as an episode in the history of the meat of the old and new worlds and the story of European colonization.
但也许，汤姆，我知道你喜欢诗。也许你应该以这首可爱的诗结束，一首非常动人的诗，实际上，它最初是用纳瓦特尔语写的，后来被翻译了。我们的悲伤哭声升起，我们的泪水倾泻而下。除了鲜花和悲伤的歌声，什么都没有。我离开了墨西哥和特拉特洛尔科，那里曾经是我们看到战士和智者的地方。我们已被压碎在地。我们躺在废墟中。除了悲伤和痛苦，墨西哥和特拉特洛尔科什么都没剩下，那里曾经是我们看到美丽和勇气的地方。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，
But perhaps, Tom, I know you love a poem. Perhaps you should end with this lovely poem, a very moving poem, actually, which was originally in Nahuatl and has since been translated. Our cries of sorrow rise up and our tears pour down. Nothing but flowers and songs of sorrow. I left in Mexico and Tlatelolco, where once we saw warriors and wise men. We have been crushed to the ground. We are lying in ruins. Nothing but grief and suffering are left in Mexico and Tlatelolco, where once we saw beauty and courage. Bye-bye. Goodbye. I'm Marina Hyde
我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦和我们的问答节目，
and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment It's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A
我们揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works We have just launched our Members Club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦和我们的问答节目，我们揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。